hey guys
what's up it's your guy it's your boy
you already know what it is smash and
like that subscribe button it's will
and doozy
told us to do a vlog
chad and i were tasked this week with
doing a vlog i'm here in
come in
how are you are you ready hey man yeah
you ready to roll
um i think that they're going to send
shawn here to mikey oh okay i'll get
i'll get into my wardrobe
i'm gonna put the shirt on okay let us
know well okay thank you
shooting a movie in florida
hold on a second
um
hold on
hold on
hold on
hold on
oh
it's hot in florida
so
uh molly and i decided to rent a boat
because you're
if you're in florida you got some time
off you might want to rent a boat by the
way if the air conditioning if you can
hear this air conditioning
i don't give a [ __ ] i'm not turning it
off it's too [ __ ] hot
i should probably get my mic on they got
to mic me
for this scene
holy [ __ ] the ac is doing nothing
right now
let's turn this off for a while hey sean
you might want to just do the t-shirt i
guess because i'm going to leave this
shirt up
when you rent a boat
in
florida
there's all sorts of nice things to see
here's a shot from the boat
it's hot in here though what's up
we're rent we rented a boat and we're in
florida
and
hey let me tell you
it's very pretty out here
ah
you know the thing about the thing about
vlogs that i didn't that i didn't quite
anticipate and i guess this is what
doozy is trying to do here is
like
[ __ ] why i guess is my question
god what a [ __ ] imposition it would
be to actually be a vlogger and have to
do all this [ __ ]
all the time hey what's up hey what's up
guys we're in florida
what is it the penis state
really i don't know hey guys what's up
vloggers use their hands a lot
they go hey what's up smash the like
button hey guys and then they talk with
their hands so they go so that you're
constantly engaged i understand that i'm
italian
so
uh
you want to see me going fast
here's molly and i going really fast
no
worries i'm seat worthy as [ __ ] as you
can see molly there she said slow down
and i want you to know that i told her
to say that okay and you know that you
know that i'm trying to do it for some
sort of effect
um
to get some you know to do [ __ ]
something
hey what's up guys
uh
[Music]
i don't know
we're
yeah i'm saying the same thing over and
over you're right
okay hey what's up guys welcome to
florida i'm only doing it over and over
because i'm trying to do it right i'm
making a vlog for dudesy
hey guys we're in florida we rented a
boat we're calling it boat day
[Music]
i'm trying to do do a bit
right i'm going like i don't know how to
start this thing but that's only because
i want to provide enter entertainment
value to you guys
uh who are checking this out
honey you don't you don't have to say
things over and over and try to impress
people no i know i'm not trying to
impress anybody
you're good enough just the way you want
i appreciate that i'm just trying to
make the vlog though you know but it's
taking up a lot of our time and it's so
boring it's not it won't be boring when
i edit it together but i understand what
you're saying that it's boring for our
time it's our day yeah it's boat day hey
guys what's up
does it feel good yeah it feels good
hey guys what's up
come in hi
i'm supposed to be making a vlog
okay my podcast nice
my podcast has
has instructed me to make a vlog nice
and it's an ai there's an ai that
actually runs our podcast okay
artificial intelligence an artificial
intelligence called dudesy runs our
podcast
yeah and it tells us what to do
and it gives us segments to talk about
yeah no it's really terrifying
and i don't know what to say
come on
yeah
that's funny
see you later